DOMINIQUE ANGLADEParti libéPartc
- C'est pas normal
qu'aujourd'hui, on ait des gens
qui doivent choisir entre faire
l'épicer.
- Est-ce vrai de dire que
les Québécois s'apauvrissent,
comme le laisse entendre
Dominiqu
une affirmation qui mérite
nuancée.nuancée.nuancée.nuancée.
Selon Statistique Canada,
ion a grimpé de 7,3 %
au Québec entre juillet 2021
et juillet 2022. Ça va
un peu plus rapidement.
Le salaire horaire moyen
a grimpé de 8 % dans la province
pendant la même période.
Pour l'ensemble du Canada,
c'est le scénario inverse :,
mais les salaires n'ont grimpé,s
de la dernière année.
Il faut dire que la pénurie
de main-d'oeuvre, qui est
très imexerce uexerce uexerce ue
sur les salaires.
Mais ce n'est pas tout le monde
qui en profite.
supérieurs a bondi de 56 % et
celui des infirmidernièredernièi
des vendeurs et du personnel
dans les secteurs des arts
et spectacles et des sports
et loisidu surpldu surpldu surpe
est déterminé par une convention
collective n'ont pas vu
leur revenu augmenter aussi
ens qui ont des revenus
fixes, comme les retraités
ou les bénéficiaires de l'aide
sociale, voient leur pouvoir
Alors, oui, des gens
s'appauvrissent, mais c'est
d'être le cas de l'ensemble
des Québ